Prosecutors in New Mexico
have just announced
that actor Alec Baldwin
and the armorer on the film
Rust will both be charged
with involuntary manslaughter
for their roles
in the fatal movie
set shooting back in October of 2021.
The film's cinematographer,
Helena Hutchins, was killed.
The film's director was injured.
Josh Campbell is back with us
from Santa Fe.
He's with Santa Fe's district at
And this is her first TV intervi
since the charging decision.
Josh Yeah, thanks.
I'm here with the district attor
Amanda Shirley.
Thank you for speaking with us.
I just want to start.
How did you come to this
prosecutor decision?
Well, along with my special pros
we got the report from the Santa
Fe County Sheriff's Office.
We initiated an extensive review
And I will say that it was a
it was a well investigated case,
we had some follow up that we ha
had to speak with some experts.
And once we read through everyth
and researched the case law
and the law here in New Mexico,
we realized that we believe
that there was probable cause to
Alec Baldwin
and hand of Gutierrez
Reid with involuntary manslaught
And what were some of the key
pieces of evidence that you used
that factored into that decision
Well, there was such a lack of s
and safety standards on that set
that there were live rounds on s
They were mixed in with regular
dummy rounds.
Nobody was checking those, or at
they weren't checking them consi
And then they somehow
got loaded into a gun
handed off to Alec Baldwin.
He didn't check it.
He didn't do
any of the things
that he was supposed to do
to make sure that he was safe
or that anyone around him was sa
And then he pointed
the gun at Helena Hutchins
and he pulled the trigger.
You talk about the safety on the
Was as part of your investigatio
was there one thing that was don
or one thing
that was said that sealed it for
that this should be prosecuted?
No, actually,
I think it was
the totality of the circumstance
that this was a really fast and
and that that nobody was doing t
There were three people
that if they had done their job
this tragedy wouldn't have happe
And that's David Hall's
Hannah Gutierrez, Reid and Alec
If they had just done their basi
duties, this,
we wouldn't be standing here.
Can you help our viewers underst
this state? State officials did
It was signed by the chief
medical investigator
saying that
there was no compelling evidence
that this was intentional. Right
So help
our viewers understand
if it's an accident,
which most people seem to think
Why is that a crime?
Because just because it's an acc
doesn't mean that it's not crimi
Our involuntary manslaughter
statute covers
unintentional killings,
unintentional homicides,
the the rest of our
homicide statutes cover intentio
but unintentional means
they didn't mean to do it.
They didn't have the intent to k
But it happened anyway.
And it happened
because of more than mere neglig
because of they
they didn't exercise due
caution or circumspection.
And that's what happened here.
And what's your response to you
know, there
might be people in Baldwin's cam
who say that you were overchargi
Well, we disagree.
And we're going to be
taking that
in front of a judge
and allowing the judge
to decide on probable cause.
But we think that there is enoug
more than enough there
to move forward on these charges
and possibly
to get through the preliminary
hearing stage and on to trial.
And can you just break down
the specific charges
so I was reading
through your announcement.
You say that
both Hannah
Gutierrez, Reid
and Alec Baldwin
have been charged with two count
of involuntary manslaughter.
Can you unpack that?
What does that mean?
Well,
and those are two counts
in the alternative.
So when this goes in front of a
the jury could find their guilty
But since they're in the alterna
they will only be sentenced
as to one count
The first part of the involuntar
that will be charging
is that they acted with without
caution and circumspection, mean
they weren't
just negligent in their duties,
but that they were on notice
that they had duties
and that they should have done
or not done
something that didn't happen
on that set, meaning
they should have checked the bul
they should have checked the gun
They shouldn't have even been
using a life gun that day.
They should have been using a ru
or a plastic gun.
All of these things go together
and show
that there was just this complac
lack of care on that set,
and it's more than negligence.
And I would say it rises to reck
The other is
goes hand in hand with a misdeme
a petty misdemeanor here in New
called negligent use of a deadly
And that is that someone
handled or used or touched a gun
in a negligent manner.
And if we once we show that,
then that can lead to the second
alternative theory
of involuntary manslaughter
does it matter for an actor?
Obviously, there's been this dis
about safety on Saturday,
the last time I interviewed you,
you even mentioned
like you were surprised to learn
you know, these sets operate lik
and some some circumstances.
But if you have an actor with wh
she thinks is a prop gun, not a
Is that actual negligence?
If it turns out that that gun
can actually shoot?
It's more than that.
Every person
that handles a gun has a duty
to make sure
that if they are going to handle
pointed at someone and pull the
that it is not going to fire a p
and kill someone.
And this is really about justice
for Lena Hutchins.
We've talked to many actors
A-list and otherwise that have s
they always check their guns
or they have someone
check it in front of them.
So it's not
an actor doesn't get a free pass
just because they're an actor.
And that's
what's so important
is that we're saying here in New
everyone is equal under the law.
Everyone has to follow their dut
and do what's right.
And take that safety into accoun
so that this doesn't ever happen
And is Baldwin being charged as
who is holding the gun
or as a producer on the set
who was negligent
about the safety standards?
Can you help describe that?
He's being charged as both.
He was the actor that pulled the
So certainly
he's he's charged as an actor,
but also as a producer.
He also had a duty to make sure
that the safe the set was safe.
And we know from our investigati
that there had been
accidental misfires prior
to this, that there were people
that were complaining
about safety on set.
And so he should have been aware
that safety was an issue on set.
And then as an actor
that day,
he should have checked that gun
checked those projectiles.
You just got more questions
than your time assured.
Do you expect any type of plea a
from Baldwin or Gutierrez, Reid?
Have those discussions started?
That's not something I can comme
at this time.
It's unethical
for a prosecutor
to talk about plea negotiations
or potential plea deals.
Were they given a heads up
that this was coming?
Yes, they were. They were.
How did those discussions feel?
We have been in,
I would
say, almost constant communicati
with with the opposing parties,
for about the last six weeks.
They didn't know exactly what wa
but they were aware that we were
contemplating charges
and they were aware of what
the contemplated charges were.
And just two more questions.
So what happens next?
So once these trials and charges
are filed as soon as tomorrow, r
Is that the plan?
It'll be before the end of this
Before the end of this month.
So then what happens?
Are these defendants
then required to come back to Ne
or will they be placed under arr
How does that work?
No, we will not be asking for an
In typical cases in this county,
the way that we handle it
as we'll send out
what's called a summons.
From that,
the court will set
what's called a first appearance
or it's basically an arraignment
And at that point, they will
either have to come here
or they might do a video arraign
We have been doing, though, sinc
and they will get their conditio
of release and enter not guilty
And finally,
last time you and I spoke,
which was right
after this tragic incident occur
you told me that,
you know, that
there was pressure out there,
people either wanting to charge
or not wanting you to charge.
One thing you said was,
you know, there's pressure.
You do not feel that pressure
and you will follow the facts
and the prosecution decision
will be made on the facts.
That was at the beginning of the
Do you still feel the same now,
looking backwards
You know, this obviously
got international attention.
Can you just talk about that?
What was it like
trying to conduct this investiga
and was it done in this
consistent manner throughout?
Oh, absolutely.
Of course, I knew there was pres
Of course,
I knew that people had feelings
or another.
But that happens in every single
And what's important to me
as a prosecutor is treating ever
equally under the law
and getting justice for the vict
And so
that pressure did not affect me
in any way whatsoever.
This was a decision
based on the facts and the evide
And I just thank you for your ti
Thank you. Appreciate it.
Okay. We'll throw it back to you
Obviously, a major decision here
that we've been waiting for in t
Now, actor
Alec Baldwin as well as the armo
charged with involvement,
involuntary manslaughter.
Josh, while you have the day,
I know she's short on time.
She said something in there that
to see if you could ask a really
She said that Alec Baldwin
pulled the trigger.
Baldwin told ABC he was adamant
he did not pull the trigger.
She is confident
Alec Baldwin pulled the trigger.
Yeah.
So my colleague Kate is asking.
So Baldwin has said that
he didn't pull the trigger.
Obviously, we know the FBI
report says that
that gun could not have gone off
without pulling the trigger.
Are you confident that he actual
the trigger? Yes, absolutely.
The FBI lab is one of the best
in the world.
And we absolutely believe
that the trigger had to have bee
in order for that gun to go off
the trigger was pulled.
So that your assessment is based
on that
FBI analysis at Quantico,
looking at the gun itself
and how it operated.
That's right.
And that's one of the reasons
that this investigation
did take a long time
We were waiting on that,
trying to make sure
we had all of the evidence and
and were able to gather
absolutely everything.
And we were sure of these charge
before we filed them.
All right.
Thank you, ma'am.
Kate, back to you.
Josh, does she know how that liv
round got on? That's up
Yeah.
One question which we've had is
do you know how the live round
actually got on the set?
We don't.
And we might not ever know
the answer to that question.
And I do believe
that's a bit of a red herring.
The point is, live rounds were t
and they weren't checked.
They should have been caught.
Three people should have been
should have been checking
those projectiles
and should have caught them.
But that wasn't a major decision
And you're
in your determination
to actually charge here, correct
And do you think that I mean,
you know,
obviously
you look at the facts of this ca
you know,
you mentioned
before how surprised
you were to see
the lack of safety on the set.
Are you also trying to
maybe send a message to other
people out there making movies
that, look, there will be conseq
Is that part of your decision?
Absolutely. Absolutely.
In New Mexico, we want you to co
We want you to film movies,
but we want you to do it safely.
And we certainly want to get jus
for anyone that is that is a vic
Like in this case.
We want to get justice for Helen
Hutchins. Right. Yeah.
And that is key.
Obviously, we've been hearing,
Kate, that there was a victim
in this case, which we have to r
Cinematographer Helena Hutchens,
although this appears to be an a
she lost her life in the sense
that it came Absolutely.
Josh, thank you very much
for the great interview.
And think please
thank the district attorney for
because I know she doesn't have
So thank you both very, very muc
Joining me now
because there's a lot to go thro
now, this now
hearing from the district
attorney herself.
Back with me, Elliot Williams,
Chloe Mills and Dutch Merrick El
What's your reaction to what you
just heard from the D.A.
Okay, so I heard three
big things there, Kate.
Number one,
the notion that accidents
can be criminal.
Look, accidents happen all the t
People get injured
all the time without any civil
or criminal liability.
But sometimes some accidents are
in the law
as so egregious
that somebody ought to be charge
with the crime and go to jail.
And she made that point
and was very explicit about it.
So, one, accidents
being criminal
to another thing she said she so
talked a lot about.
It was
things were fast and loose on th
and they failed to carry out the
what the terms used
were basic duties to secure the
and ensure that dangerous weapon
or anything that might hurt
somebody was secured
And she made that point.
This gets back to the point
we were talking
about earlier on negligence,
where people have a duty to ensu
that they are behaving in a mann
as other reasonable people would
or should behave
in the same circumstance.
And finally,
and this is a big one,
she noted that
people complained on the set
and there were reports
that a number of staff on
the set had left
shortly before this shooting.
And one of the things
that they'd complained about
were the conditions for safety
for crew and actors on set.
That's a point that certainly pl
into criminal charges,
given that
the actors and or producers and
she noted that Alec
Baldwin is both
were on notice
that there might have been hazar
so a number of things
that, you know, she's she's
speaking and prosecutors speak.
But really bolstering all of her
for how she got to
manslaughter
killing someone in an accidental
Very interesting, Chloe.
You've statements in now
from Alec Baldwin. What is he sa
Kate, so I have a
statement from Alec Baldwin's at
that they just said to me.
This is how it reads, quote,
This decision distorts
Alaina Hutchins
tragic death
and represents
a terrible miscarriage of justic
Mr.
Baldwin had no reason to believe
there was a live bullet in the g
or anywhere on the movie set.
He relied on the professionals w
he worked, who assured him
the gun did not have live rounds
We will fight these charges
and we will win.
Kate, I've told you that when I
with Alec Baldwin
over the summer,
he was adamant
that he did not pull the trigger
I just pulled some of what he to
over the summer while we
when we sat down,
he said,
I pulled the hammer all the way
without locking it and the gun w
I've never played with a gun.
I never took a gun and pointed i
at somebody and click the thing.
I never pulled the trigger
on a gun aimed at someone in my
And you could probably find
countless people
that would testify to that fact.
So, I mean, just based on the st
that we just got moments ago
from Alec Baldwin's attorney,
we know that he is going to figh
We know that
he will not take a plea deal,
that he will see this
through to a jury trial.
And we are still waiting to hear
from Baldwin himself Kate.
All right, Chloe,
thanks for bringing us that.
Dutch,
I want your reaction to everythi
that we heard, the description
that the D.A.
just laid
out of the kind of how
it was played, kind of fast and
I think she said
the complacency is a word
that she used on the set.
What's the impact?
Now that we have these charges c
what is the impact, do you think
going to be on the industry?
Well, complacency on that set is
When you look at the photographs
of how
the prop truck was handled,
it was look like
the truck had been tipped over.
Nothing was organized
the way the carts were just stre
And that low budget show,
they had cut a lot of corners
and didn't have a lot of time
and didn't didn't
hold themselves to the standards
that most of Hollywood does.
I think the changes that
should come about is
especially the first
ad insinuating itself
into the situation, handling a g
No first aid
I've ever heard of has done that
That's a royal royal.
No.
And when it said that,
when the prosecutor said that Ba
should have checked the gun,
that is not the actor's responsi
The actor puts a great deal of t
in us, the armors
and the prop department,
to make sure that
while we make sure we make it
look as real as humanly possible
we also make it as safe as possi
And he was assured by a crew per
the first lady in this instance
that that gun was, quote, cold
or didn't have any blanks in it
or wasn't dangerous,
and he acted accordingly.
So he may have liability,
but he put his trust in our crew
and that crew person,
the armor and the aide
failed him terribly.